year that I'd lost you know pretty much
my life savings I just went on the road
and I have your life savings that much
yeah like I heard like it was a couple
of million dollar loan oh no no no no
this was everything you've worked hard
for is gone this is like we're talking
in the possibly tens of millions of
dollars I would kill myself I didn't
think about that not oh no no it's not
that no you go ahead go ahead I'm sorry
no the Opie's are I don't know if I
would kill myself I don't want no that
wasn't definitely not an option if
anything what it was gonna be is how can
I show the people that loved me and that
are here still with me that I'm a
resilient dude and the one thing
that I always believed in I didn't
believe in a lot of things in myself and
I was pretty mean to myself for a lot of
years pretty self loathing but I knew I
could make people laugh and I got out on
stage for that next year and I did a
hundred arenas I think I rented them
myself with a little bit of money that I
had in stocks that he couldn't take
because you can't just pull stock money
out but once I looked liquidated all
that and did like a forensics audit this
is all really boring
I did a friend's excited liquefied and I
took the remaining parcels of funds and
I rented arenas myself like hauls how
much does this cost you um I you know a
B arena somewhere would cost me about
like mmm you know 70 grand for an
off-night no basketball game no hockey
game so you had to make big theory over
70 grand
yeah but I'm setting the ticket price
that I'm taking the door I'm taking the
door I'm getting the merch I'm doing it
all because I'm renting it so I'm paying
my crew and then I'm pocketing 84% of
each arena
how much would insure in a make could it
make could it could be in the hundreds
of thousands of dollars everything from
and you took a chance because you might
not have you like well nobody's there
whatever you know we're talking 2010 is
well which is like worst possible time
for the economy everything in years
after you've already had you know you
ain't even out I'd already bottomed out
and I hit the eight-year crest which you
know you know it's gonna
at some point and so I'm coming down the
other side of the thing and now I'm just
gonna have to like I've got my nest egg
until the next wave hits or whenever I
come up with a good idea and so
every night I would go out I play these
arenas I sold them out everywhere I went
you name an arena in US and Canada I
played it and by the end of that year I
made back everything he'd stolen from me
pretty much in like 14 or 15 months oh
my god how does that feel the best
changed my life because now I don't do
shows Michael I don't perform anything
or anywhere I don't take any gig I say
no to a lot I have problems sometimes
with my team because I said I'm not
doing anything that I can't let those
fans that save my life know that this is
important to me and I want you to be a
part of it so if that means I do less
work but when I do do work or tour it's
the higher quality which is what's
happening with the TEL like it is tour
people are going I saw you ten
times over 20 years I didn't think you
could exceed my expectations after and
then they named a favorite show and
they're like you blew me away
tonight